[Music]
on this tuesday night allegations about
a top
soldier a global news investigation into
former chief of the defense staff
general jonathan vance made in canada a
new plan to produce a covet vaccine
tens of millions of novavax covet 19
doses
will be made right here at home why it
won't be ramped up
until later this year the challenge
containing
highly transmissible variants to let up
now
is like putting with the new variants in
the population that's like putting
gasoline on the fire
we look at the risk to schools and he
became famous for walking laps in his
garden
and inspiring millions the tributes to
captain
sir tom moore
global national with donna friesen
good evening and thanks for joining us
we begin tonight with allegations
against canada's former top soldier
general jonathan vance is accused of
engaging in inappropriate sexual
behavior
as a senior leader in the canadian armed
forces our ottawa bureau chief mercedes
stevenson has the exclusive details
mercedes general jonathan vance was the
force behind
operation honor the military's pledge to
root out sexual misconduct from its
ranks
now general vance finds himself facing
allegations
after multiple sources approached global
news alleging he behaved inappropriately
with subordinate women
including during his time as chief of
the defense staff
a source with direct knowledge came
forward to global news
alleging a relationship with sexually
explicit exchanges
and repeated private meetings global
news has viewed evidence that appears to
support this
late this afternoon global news
contacted the female subordinate alleged
to have had a relationship with vance
she confirmed the allegations but asked
to remain anonymous
and global news has agreed to honor her
request
vance has denied allegations of
inappropriate behavior in two separate
phone calls with global news
in his first response vance suggested he
only knew the woman in a professional
context
he also denied having any direct
communication with her
but vance later acknowledged they had
dated engaged crown new brunswick
where they were both posted in 2001
while in separate chains of command
vance told global news that he had been
quote holding back in his initial
response
because he did not want to quote betray
confidences
vance said that while he had met the
woman on multiple occasions
the relationship was not sexual vance
denied knowledge of sexually explicit
communications
and indicated they could be fabricated
vance described himself as a supporter
and a friend and said the woman sought
his advice about joining the lawsuit for
victims of sexual misconduct
and harassment in the military there are
no allegations that the alleged
relationship
was not consensual senior military
officers and defense officials describe
any relationship between the chief of
the defense staff and a subordinate
member as
problematic due to the power imbalance
former brigadier general
daniel menard was charged in 2010 under
section 129 of the national defense act
for having a relationship with the
subordinate while leading canada's task
force
in afghanistan he was relieved of his
command
and replaced by vance sources also
alleged to global news that vance made a
sexual comment towards a second much
younger junior soldier
before becoming chief of the defense
staff which a source described as
unwanted that comment contained in
documents obtained by global news was
sent from vance's military email account
to a 25-year-old female corporal in 2012
when vance was a major general an email
from vance's account
raises the prospect of going to a
clothing optional
vacation destination with her vance told
global news he has
no recollection of the exchange and
suggested that if it did occur
he would have intended it as a joke
rather than a solicitation
he also said he would be willing to
apologize if he did make the comment
the allegations come a little over two
weeks after vance formally handed over
command of the military
vance's tenure as chief of the defense
staff was marked by a cultural and legal
reckoning over rampant sexual misconduct
in the military's ranks in a statement
the prime minister's office told global
news that it takes all allegations of
workplace misconduct
extremely seriously and ensures that all
processes are fallout
noting that no one should ever feel
unsafe at work within the canadian
military
defense minister harjit sajin's office
told global news
that the minister has always insisted
that any and all
allegations brought to his attention
should be reported to the appropriate
authorities
so that any necessary investigations can
begin
donna all right mercedes stevenson in
ottawa thanks
turning now to the pandemic after weeks
of dropping case numbers it may appear
the kovid 19 crisis
is beginning to ease but there continue
to be warnings canada is not in the
clear
more cases of the highly contagious new
variants are being detected every day
new brunswick and saskatchewan confirmed
their first cases of the uk variant
today
at least 148 variant cases have been
detected across the country
it's likely many more are undetected the
concern is they could spread much faster
than vaccines are rolling out
today the prime minister announced a
plan with vaccine maker
novovax to produce a covid19 vaccine
here in canada
this is a major step forward to get
vaccines made
in canada for canadians
the novovax vaccine though has not been
approved for use in canada yet
and building the production facility in
montreal will take months
abigail beeman has the details tonight
on what's promised
and the challenge of delivering on it
tens of millions of novavax covet 19
doses
will be made right here at home there
are
asterisks attached to the prime
minister's announcement the novovax
vaccine needs to be approved by health
canada
the national research council's new
plant needs to be built
the production facility should be
completed this summer
but that doesn't mean vaccines will flow
right away
the industry minister clarified so we
expect by the end of the year
to be in a position to be producing
vaccines and we're talking around 2
million doses a month
neither novovax nor the nrc responded to
an interview request
but veto at the university of
saskatchewan the vaccine and infectious
disease organization
painted a similar picture the prime
minister announced it can produce
up to 40 million doses a year once its
new facility is built
the schedule is for construction to be
completed by the end of october it
doesn't expect to be making vaccines
until about the middle of 2022.
these are very complex facilities and so
the regulator will want to come in
and make sure that what we have built is
is to
the standard and meets all the necessary
requirements
ottawa also announced a further 25.1
million dollars for precision nano
systems for its new vaccine facility
slated to be finished by march 2023 the
company says it can produce up to
240 million doses of its new
self-amplifying rna vaccine
if approved rna vaccines as a general
class
will be the technology that allows for
to to chase after any
mutations of of uh the pathogen of the
of the virus so it's a very flexible
technology
we also have to prepare for future
variants and
the investment in those technologies and
the manufacturing capacity to produce
those technologies
i think is still going to be very
important in the future ottawa has a
deal with nofavx to buy
52 million doses with an option for 24
million more precision nanosystems and
veto are both working on canadian
vaccines of their own
veto in phase one of clinical trials in
halifax
precision expects to start trials this
summer and while the prime minister is
committed to getting
all canadians a vaccine by september
none of those
will be made in canada abigail beeman
global news
ottawa the pandemic has exposed how
little vaccine production there is in
canada decades ago canada's vaccine
industry though was robust
that started to change in the 1980s when
according to the canadian press a number
of companies including astrazeneca
and johnson and johnson shut down their
canadian operations
today two companies manufacture vaccines
here both
are foreign owned french company sanofi
produces vaccines for diseases such as
whooping cough
in toronto and british company
glaxosmithkline produces
influenza vaccines in quebec one of the
vaccines approved for use in canada the
pfizer biontech vaccine requires special
syringes to extract
every dose possible from each vial the
federal government says
it has ordered 64 million of what are
called low dead space syringes they
maximize the extraction of doses from
each vial
pfizer biontech is pushing health canada
to stretch the number of doses in each
vial from five to six
the first shipment of one million of the
special syringes is expected
this week new brunswick's chief medical
officer
made clear today how difficult it could
be to get ahead of the highly contagious
new variants
from january 5th to january 28th new
brunswick recorded 567 cases of covid19
if those numbers involve the uk variant
it's estimated new brunswick
would have had over a thousand cases and
in a best-case scenario case numbers
would jump to over
6 000 by the end of february as heather
urex west reports the variants are
sweeping through other countries and are
now
being detected in canadian schools new
brunswick is taking no chances after
detecting its first three cases of the
uk variant
officials are already considering
additional measures to prevent
further spread it is a really fast
moving strain it infects people very
very quickly and in higher numbers
the biggest concern is what happens if
these variants are allowed to spread
the uk variant has already been linked
to outbreaks at a long-term care center
and a meat packing plant in ontario
in bc and alberta officials are now
dealing with exposures at day cares and
schools as well this is definitely
something we've been wanting to avoid
you know these variants do appear to
have the ability to spread more easily
and that could you know really challenge
our defense mechanisms and our safety
protocols in school
four cases of the variant have been
traced to an outbreak at an alberta
daycare
and in two calgary schools students with
the variant attended
class in bc 80 people at a maple ridge
secondary school
are now being tested after a covet 19
positive person
attended school after being exposed to
the uk variant
those tests will also undergo genome
sequencing
as bc expands screening for the new
variants we're
for example doing full genome sequencing
of all
cases in young people in school-aged
children canada is currently only
sequencing a sample of covid19 tests for
the variants
raising concerns there could be unknown
instances of community spread
i think there are definitely signs that
the variants are at least transmitted to
a certain extent
in community and we probably are not
detecting them all
it's why dr teresa tam is urging
provinces to be
very cautious around easing restrictions
in alberta there are plans in place to
reopen restaurants to
in-person dining as early as next week
i think there's a very good possibility
that we're already seeing community
spread in alberta
to let up now is like putting with the
new variants
in the population that's like putting
gasoline on fire
and it's just not a good idea because as
health officials have warned
for weeks if these variants are allowed
to take hold in the community
everything could change heather eurex
west global news
calgary after six weeks of the strictest
lockdown measures in the country some
areas of quebec are having restrictions
eased premier francois lagos stressed
though the battle is not over
and many tough measures are still in
place amanda gilliwicki is in montreal
tonight
amanda what is changing there well donna
the biggest change coming is that
non-essential businesses
will be allowed to reopen across the
province under very strict guidelines
that includes retail stores shopping
malls and personal grooming centers like
hair salons
as well as museum museums also cegep and
university students will be allowed to
return to in-person classes they've been
online since the fall
restaurants though in the montreal area
as well as other red zones
will remain closed
chef antonio park prepares salmon for
his lunch rush
lately though that rush has been
underwhelming
for four months now park's revered
montreal restaurant has only been open
for takeout and delivery
it is very difficult because the
government doesn't give us really
flexibility nor
a lot of help so it's very difficult
about 10 percent of quebec restaurants
have closed permanently since the
pandemic began
the hard hit industry estimates up to 40
percent could collapse this year
we need to know when we will be reopened
how we will be reopened
and we need to have a comprehensive
financial aid package
with covent numbers steadily falling
premier francoise ago has promised weary
quebecers a slight easing of some
restrictions
it's unlikely montreal restaurants will
reopen but non-essential businesses
including retail stores and malls are
expecting a break
we're at the point where retail needs to
reopen
for the population and for the retail
owners because
we're at the limit at this point
businesses say online sales aren't
enough
and it has been extremely difficult
because in a business like ours
curbside pickup and e-commerce do not
reply
replace they don't replace bricks and
mortar business
vados runs burke's jewelry stores across
canada
he says it's critical they open soon i
know for sure that if
if we can't operate for valentine's
many retailers will not make it beyond
february
now the softening of these rules take
effect next week quebec's curfew though
will remain in place
it will be under review by february 25th
donna
amanda gilawiki in montreal thanks the
big storm bearing down on atlantic
canada coming up the wild weather plus
what furry forecasters predict for the
weeks ahead
they are cleaning up on the u.s east
coast after that powerful nor'easter the
slow-moving storm dumped more than 70
centimeters of snow in pennsylvania
where at least four people died and
a disaster emergency has been declared
nearly a meter of snow fell
in new jersey and in new york schools
and most vaccination sites
are closed winter storm warnings are
still in effect from maryland
to maine
that same stormfront is taking a swipe
at atlantic canada too many
schools are closed driving is
treacherous and there are widespread
power outages
nova scotia is bracing for 80
millimeters of rain and winds
gusting up to 100 kilometers per hour
new brunswick is expecting up to 45
centimeters of snow and ice pellets
and in pei up to 25 centimeters of
blowing snow
and freezing rain is in the forecast
well every day can feel a bit like
groundhog day right now but today is
actually
the real groundhog day and without a
shadow of a doubt the science points to
an early spring
no shadow okay so it's not
real science it's schubernakity sam in
nova scotia he emerged from his borough
this morning and apparently he did not
see his shadow and
the groundhog science says that means
spring-like weather is on the way soon
ontario's wyatt and willie backed that
up with a tweet fans of spring
rejoice and early spring is around the
corner there you have it
poisoned and now facing more prison time
ahead the fate of alexi navalny
a russian court has sentenced opposition
leader alexei navalny to three and a
half years in a penal colony
navalny becomes russia's most prominent
political prisoner the court ruled he'd
violated the terms of his parole from a
2014 money laundering conviction a case
he says was fabricated and politically
motivated
as the judge read the ruling navalny
smiled at his wife yulia
and he traced the outline of a heart on
the glass in the prisoner's box
navalny was arrested january 17th after
returning from germany where he was
recovering from a nerve agent poisoning
an assassination attempt he says
president putin ordered
before the sentence navalny told the
court you can't jail
the whole country
more than 500 of his supporters were
arrested outside the courthouse today
the verdict is being widely condemned as
targeting the victim of a poisoning
rather than those responsible
prime minister justin trudeau tweeted
today we call for his immediate release
as well as a release
of the peaceful protesters and
journalists who have been detained in
recent weeks
with time served navalny will spend two
years and eight months behind bars his
lawyers
plan to appeal
next farewell to captain tom
just follow the money
one of cinema's best known lines
delivered by actor
hal holbrook who has passed away his
career spanned six decades on film
television and on stage holbrook died
january 23 at his home in california his
assistant made the news public last
night
holbrook is remembered for dozens of
roles from playing king lear to abe
lincoln but
the standout was his one-man show mark
twain tonight
the show was his creation and he
performed it
thousands of times
holbrook was 95 years old
there is another passing to report
tonight captain sir tom moore who became
famous as he approached his 100th
birthday
has passed away after testing positive
for covid19
cared for in his final hours by staff at
the national health care service
he raised millions for prime minister
boris johnson paid tribute to the
retired army officer today calling him
not just a national inspiration but a
beacon of hope for the whole world
captain sir tom moore was a hero
in the truest sense of the word in the
dark days of the second world war
he fought for freedom and in the face of
this country's
deepest post-war crisis he united us all
the queen who awarded moore a knighthood
this summer said in a statement
she very much enjoyed meeting captain
sir tom and his family at windsor last
year
and that her thoughts and those of the
royal family are with them
redmond shannon reminds us why an
elderly man doing laps in his garden
captured our hearts most war veterans
who live to reach 100
might reasonably accept that their best
days are behind them
but not captain sir tom moore his book
was called
tomorrow will be a good day an attitude
that propelled him up and down his
backyard
raising 57 million dollars for health
care workers
i'm delighted that the effort that we
set up
for such a small sum has turned into
this
enormous sum of money and the cause is
so good
a senior a war veteran a unifying figure
if captain tom hadn't existed the
british government might have had to
invent him
he became not just a national
inspiration
but a beacon of hope for the world that
global fame didn't go to his head
but revealed his humility i've spoken to
so many
countries throughout the world i've had
to
pick up my geography quite a bit that
was quite amazing
all those places the british army made
their man an honorary colonel
and the queen made him a knight so
thomas sounds very nice
but i i inside haven't changed
nothing nothing's turned inside moore
even met with british
sporting royalty i knew i had to dress
up today
moore died after testing positive for
covet 19
the same unforgiving virus he did so
much to tackle
an irony not lost on those who admired
him this may be a bit symbolic or a bit
poetic but
if so it's a very sad poem like i work
for the nhs and
it means a huge amount for us everything
you've done an incredible life you've
lived
thanks very much thank you very much
that just about sums it up
redmond shannon global news london
and that is global national for this
tuesday i'm donna friesen tonight's your
canada is this neighborhood ice rink
in the nation's capital thanks for
watching i'll see you back here tomorrow
take care of yourselves bye-bye
you